- Hey everybody, it's Gary Vaynerchuck
and this is Pod Sessions number three
if you're just joining.
I've always wanted to bring
interesting people together
and talk about current events.
I think that that dude from Swingers
Fav?
I always get his last name wrong.
Favrieau?
- Favreau.
Jon Favreau had that dinner party
of dinner thing that caught
my attention on cable
like 17 years ago when I
used to consume content
as my three guests will say in a minute,
they consume an obnoxious
amount of content.
We'll speak to that issue in a minute.
But, finally we're doing it.
Obviously, I referenced
before, my career change
when I started doing these jam sessions
at South by Southwest and other places
with people that went on to
become the biggest investors and makers
of the greatest apps,
and I think we're living
through a culture shift
right now around.
It's why row crushing it.
I just think there's more room,
way more room, for us to do our thing
in this internet thing than we realize
and even I didn't realize how much,
and that's all I focused on for a decade.
So I realized wow,
there's a lot more to go.
I've quadruple downed
over the last 24 months.
It's changed a lot for me
and I try to bring on people
who I think are interesting
entrepreneurs doing fun stuff
and also have a point
of view on that world.
And so that's what we're doing here.
So I'm super excited for these three.
One I know pretty darn well.
The other two I'm getting to know,
and actually had meetings with
as recently as this morning
for the first time.
Even though Jerry's played
a bunch of basketball
with my crew.
- Yes.
And we'll get into that.
And I'm excited about this show,
I think it's gonna be a good one.
So why don't we do the introduction part.
Or, I'd like you to introduce yourself,
what you do.
And maybe like a quick, one minute recap,
four to six bullets on yourself.
Why don't you go?
- I knew I was gonna have to.
- [Gary] Yes, ladies first.
- It's always the worst.
Alright, so.
- You think going first is worse?
Let's talk about that first.
Before we go into intros.
- Going first is worst.
- You were about to say
it's always the worst.
- [Danielle] Well because
they have time to think about
what they're going to say.
- I promise I won't think.
- Alright, then just
focus on what I'm saying.
(laughing)
Liz will think, I know Liz
well enough to know that.
- [Gary] You know everybody at this table.
- We've known each other for
like five years now, I think.
- [Danielle] And Gary, you're my people.
I tell everyone that I'm the third--
- [Gary] Do you know everybody?
Do you tell everybody
you're the fourth amigo?
- No I was just going
to say I tell everyone
that I'm the three something
female version of you.
I'm really flattering myself.
- The amount of people that tell me
they're the female Gary V is absurd.
- [Danielle] But I think
I'm going to go with that.
- [Gary] I respect that.
- And My dad is in PR
so it works, anyways.
Other than my dad's name being Gary,
my name's Danielle Snyder.
I have a label called Danny
Jo with my sister Jodie.
- Who's here by the way for
moral support and to answer
all real questions.
- [Danielle] She's my other
half we share a brain.
She's here as my life line
in case you guys want to talk sports.
- If you guys share a
brain what percentage
is you and what percentage is her?
- 50/50 it's even Steven.
- [Garry] Cause I always
thought she was like 87 percent.
Okay keep going.
- If anyone is going
to be 80 it's me, but;
no I'm kidding, she's the better half.
- [Gary] Yeah she does have the micro fan.
- So we have a label.
We're going on our tenth year anniversary.
- Wow congrats.
- [Danielle] Which is
pretty phenominal, right?
- Can you make a limited
edition piece of jewelry
with a ten on it and just give it to me
so I can flip it on ebay in 14 years?
- I'm actually glad this is being filmed
because I wanted to talk
about a collaboration
during the show with Gary Vaynerchuck.
So absolutely, we will.
- [Gary] Okay.
(laughter)
- This is announced.
Announced a collab.
- Tyler; he can push
it on all his channels.
- Right, got it.
- So we've had--
- [Gary] And you'll keep how
much percentage of the action?
- [Danielle] 100%.
- Understood.
Keep going.
(laughter)
- [Gary] Sounds like a non profit event.
Let's keep it going
- So, we've had a label for 10 years.
A lifestyle brand.
It's built on our sisterhood.
Our community.
We're known for our statement jewelry
and having made our collection,
the large majority of it
here in New York City.
And within the last year
we've expanded into fitness,
health and wellness,
travel,
and story telling.
- By executing it yourself
or by licensing the brand
to people making products in those worlds.
- Executing it to ourselves
with the intention of--
- Possibly, go it.
Understood.
- So, we most recently
launched a fitness movement
called boxerina that's a
hybrid of boxing and ballet.
And we're using that as a
tool to build the community.
- That's cool.
- And sweat with the people that we love
and travel to our
favorite places with them
under the Dannijo Travels retreat series.
So, a lot to talk about.
But I want you guys to fill me in
so I can think about
what I want to say next.
- She's passing us the baton now.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- My name is Liz Eswein.
I have worked in the influencer space
for probably six years now.
- You started when you were three.
- [Liz] I started when
I was three, exactly.
(laughter)
I was actually in college.
I went to NYU.
And, I had read an article that Instagram
had just raised to series
A of seven million dollars
and they had a million users.
But back story.
I had gotten really sick
with chronic lime disease.
My junior year so,
So, I had always said I was gonna go work
in publishing and advertising
with a background,
I had an internship at Condé Nast.
- [Gary] Yup.
And, I was barely getting through school.
And so, yeah.
- [Gary] Because of the disease.
- [Liz] Yeah.
- Not like me, who's a
hardcore D and F student
- [Liz] No.
Totally.
- By the way, Tyler.
When is my report card getting here?
- [Tyler] It's public schools.
It takes a little bit.
- It takes a little bit.
- [Gary] I can't get too mad at you
because I already got it once.
Flashed it, posted an instagram photo,
but then lost it.
Which probably speaks to why
there was so many D's and F's on it.
(laughter)
But this time I'm gonna get it.
I'm gonna frame it somewhere massive.
- [Liz] Put it up on the wall.
Probably right there.
I'm gonna move Macho Man down
and I'm gonna put it right there.
So as soon as you walk in,
it sets the tone of what
you're dealing with.
I'm sorry, keep going.
- Cool, yeah.
So, I was just in bed one
day and read the article.
Tried to make a few names.
They were taken.
And I was, well I live in New York
so here we are.
And New York City was available.
And it registered.
- [Gary] So funny.
- And I kind of forgot about it.
And I didn't tell anyone because
when you sign up for myspace or something
I'm not saying;
hey Dani, I signed up for myspace.
- [Gary] It was a different time.
And then
that took off rather slowly.
The photos on there were atrocious.
They're still there.
You can take a look.
I won't delete them.
- 'Cause you took'em.
- [Liz] Yeah, they were iPhone photos.
- So you're smart, but not creative.
(laughter)
- [Gary] No, no!
That was a question.
That wasn't a statement.
- [Liz] I would say a hybrid of the two.
- [Gary] Respect.
- But there are people far
more creative than I am.
Both my parents are entrepreneurs
and I have loved watching them
start their own businesses
and I always wanted to do that.
Then I graduated and
started to see a shift
and why wouldn't a brand pay 40 grand
for a
someone with 100 thousand followers
as opposed to 40 grand for a print page
or a print magazine that had
100 thousand in circulation.
So yeah,
I met
two of...
Should I go into it, briefly?
Okay, cool.
- Everything.
That's what we're here for.
- [Liz] So yeah.
I met my first two co-founders.
And we started what was
really the first influencer
Instagram marketing agency at that time.
Nike was our first client.
They paid us 50 dollars in cash.
And I remember telling my mom.
- [Danielle] We made it.
Mom, I can make money!
(laughter)
It was awesome.
And she was like, oh Jesus.
And I was there for two years
and then left to start
an agency called cycle
which was part of a
larger full service agency
called laundry service.
- [Gary] Yup.
- And we represented a roster of talent
and really,
I think provided a
backbone to their careers
that were launching in this space.
And then we were acquired.
So long story short on how this all--
- [Gary] And that was good for you.
So, you're rich.
(laughter)
- [Liz] Jesus.
- [Danielle] Great.
- [Gary] That was a question again.
Do you want to answer it?
- No.
- [Gary] Okay, cool; Jared?
Thank you, I'm glad; I'm pumped to hear.
- [Danielle] She's passing
on the baton to Jared.
- So you still own @newyorkcity.
- Yeah.
But I wanted to parlay.
- [Gary] And you want
to sell that to D Rock?
- No!
- [Danielle] Ask her the
most important question.
Is she gonna instagram all of us?
- [Liz] Absolutely.
- [Gary] DJ, you need to calm it down.
- [Danielle] What?
Diaz, you need to calm it down.
- [Danielle] No, but it wasn't that.
- [Liz] Yeah, we're good.
- She's my people.
- [Liz] But yeah, I wanted to parlay--
- [Gary] So far, I'm you're people.
She's you're people.
Jerry?
- Jerry is my new people.
We just met, actually.
- [Gary] You never met Jerry before?
- His wife is gorgeous.
I know everything about his life.
- We did.
We basically did a podcast out there.
- How'd it go?
- [Jerry] It went well.
I will be up later at six o'clock.
- [Gary] Did you guys film it?
- [Liz] No.
- No, we didn't see.
That's why we need you,
because you're a big thinker.
- [Gary] And remind team,
we put out our podcast at 5:59 PM.
Alright, Jer.
- [Jerry] And by the way,
going last is not it's
all it's cracked up to be
'cause now I gotta
follow those two stories.
- You're gonna be great, Jerry.
(laughter)
- Now you're gonna hear about
the chubby Italian kid
from Bensonhurst, Brooklyn.
- [Gary] That's fine.
But now, you look so phenomenal.
You're on the right side
of this conversation.
It's the worst when it's the reverse.
- [Jerry] I know, right?
- [Gary] You've got it.
You've figured it out.
- I've been there, too.
I guess, I am Jerry Ferrara.
I am an actor.
Which, growing up in Bensonhurst, Brooklyn
was not the easiest trade, I would say.
There's not a lot of other
actors where I was growing up.
So I was kind of little bit of the--
- [Gary] But you were right from the get.
- Teenage years.
About 15, 16 years old.
It was really of a love of movies
and television that I just
wanted to find a way in.
I could have easily have been
a camera operator, or an editor.
I just wanted to be in that world.
- [Gary] But you started with
actor and then you set it?
- [Jerry] I stumbled into acting
'cause I was failing out
of a community college.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Yes.
Doing it right.
- Our kind of people.
- You were my kind of people, Jerry.
- [Jerry] I took an acting class
'cause I was told the
professor will give us an A
if you just show up.
So I took this acting class.
Alright, I'm gonna finally
prove to my mom I can.
- [Gary] This is like golf or swimming.
- Yeah.
I'm gonna prove it to
my mom I can get an A.
(laughter)
I went into this acting class
and it was totally terrifying.
I remember walking in
and being like I don't know
if this is what I'm supposed to do
but I think this is what I want to do.
- It felt weird and right.
- [Jerry] It just, yeah.
I just wanted to do it again.
And I never stopped from that moment on.
I started doing extra work.
I was an extra in Oz on HBO.
I was an extra in the
pilot of Sex and the City.
- [Gary] What?
- Yes.
Shot a club scene at Limelight in 1998.
I was in that scene.
- Were you killing it in the background?
You could barely see me.
I've never revealed what frame it is.
- [Gary] Fans, please find this
and tweet me with the screenshot.
Please find this.
- [Jerry] Good luck.
It's really hidden, I
looked way different.
But, I'll wrap it up quickly.
Right around there I knew I needed
to venture out west.
'Cause at the time was
where the business was.
It's where the action was.
Moved out to LA.
About four or five years into it
I got cast in Entourage which--
- [Gary] Worked out.
- It worked out.
(laughter)
Lasted eight seasons.
And then, bounced around in movies
after that for a little
while trying to reinvent
because, you become that character.
- I mean, let's get to the punchline.
- [Jerry] I talked about
that at some point.
- I mean, let's talk
about for four seconds.
I mean, you do look different enough,
that maybe you have a prayer
of it not being as bad as it could be.
- [Jerry] Right.
- But it must happen a lot
that people reference you as turtle.
- [Jerry] It certainly, in the moment.
- [Gary] At the time.
- In, say, season three of the show.
- [Gary] That's the only way
you were referenced in life.
- It was it.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Jerry] I do poke holes in
the whole typecasting theory
because where I was going,
now I've been working on this
show power for five years.
- [Gary] Yup.
- I'm kind of typecast again.
Now, it's outside.
I just met a few people here.
We were like, Proctor, oh my God!
That's my character.
- [Gary] Really?
- Yeah.
So, it almost disproves
the theory, if typecast--
- [Gary] Bring those people to me.
Guys, fire those fuck-faces.
(laughter)
- [Jerry] No.
- [Gary] Who?
- [Jerry] Don't tell!
- Anthony?
Bring him.
(laughter)
I just inadvertently dimed someone out.
- [Gary] Yeah, go get Anthony right now.
- No, no, no.
Don't!
- [Gary] No, I'm firing him
right in his fucking face.
Right now.
- Oh, guys.
Someone's really going
to get this poor guy.
- [Liz] She's actually getting him.
- [Gary] This is real life.
This is what we do on the pod sessions.
Episode three.
- [Jerry] He didn't say like.
He said Power more than Proctor.
- [Liz] Don't make him cry.
- Dude.
- [Gary] You referenced
him as his new character?
- [Jerry] We talked about Power.
- [Gary] Do you know
about his OG character?
- Of course.
- Okay, get out of here.
- [Jerry] I didn't mean that.
- It's okay.
He'll see what happens when
he watches the podcast.
- Where I was going with that
was in a way,
it kind of disproves typecasting as whole.
Because if I was--
- [Gary] Yeah, if you can execute it.
- And only was turtle.
- [Gary] That's exactly right.
- How do I get typecast again.
There's people who don't
know anything about Entourage
and only know me from Power.
- [Gary] And so your goal is
to be typecast seven times.
- [Jerry] As many times as possible.
- Good for you, buddy.
- 'Cause all that means
is that I worked a lot.
- [Gary] That's exactly right.
- And here I am.
Back in New York.
Still working and grinding.
- [Gary] So what are you gonna do next?
eSports.
You're doing a bunch of stuff,
we'll get all into that.
- You want some cool eSports stuff.
- [Liz] He got married recently.
- [Jerry] Just got married.
- Thank you @newyork.
- [Danielle] I was gonna
say that, too though.
- [Gary] You referenced it earlier.
- Someone actually
decided to stay with this
for the rest of their life.
That did happen, shockingly enough.
- So life is good.
- [Jerry] Life is good.
- This is my favorite part of the show.
I go right to it.
- [Liz] I just have to say this.
This is a good group.
- [Gary] Is this, Liz?
- Yeah, this is a great group.
- [Gary] Why'd you dodge my question?
- What question?
- [Gary] Yeah.
(laughter)
- You're gonna ask him that question?
- [Gary] We know that answer.
I'm trying to teach the kids
that you can actually make money
in influencer marketing.
- [Liz] Oh, totally.
- Alright.
I want to know what you're
currently obsessed with.
What is happening in culture
or in your life
that you're obsessed with.
Now the last show,
all three people went around
and made fucking
- [Danielle] Bullshit answers.
Martin Luther King, Gandhi manifestos.
- [Danielle] Tyler summed it up.
- It was literally
peace, health,
world love.
I mean
you bought some weird pillow
at bed, bath and beyond,
'cause you slobber at night
and this pillow absorbs it
and now you're obsessed with this pillow.
Or you follow this new
weird instagram account.
Back to your world, Liz.
In my world.
That has 600 followers,
but you believe it's
gonna have four million.
Or Jerry, you and I had this
meeting earlier and I said
the hip hop artists, maybe.
- [Jerry] Yes.
What are you currently obsessed with.
Jerry you go first, we're
going the other way around.
- I was expecting it.
You know what?
I'm ready for it.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- I promise this is not a plug.
I am obsessed with gaming.
- [Gary] But that's okay
'cause D has been plugging
all day.
- With gaming and
eSports and I'm currently
a scout and a consultant for the Knicks
on their gaming squad.
And that requires me
being on Twitch, day in,
day night,
scouting these players.
It's like the closest I can come
to being a part of a
real sports franchise.
- [Gary] So, you're
literally looking at Twitch.
- [Jerry] I'm scouting.
- And you're scouting.
- [Jerry] Yes.
You're like, I think Ricky in Minnesota,
we should sign him.
He's a good player.
- [Jerry] Well, draft him.
That's what the cool thing
is about the 2K leagues.
I call them kids.
- [Gary] Oh, this is for the 2K league.
- This is for the MBA 2K league.
- [Gary] How good are you at 2K?
- [Jerry] I'm pretty good.
But I can't touch
some of these guys who have
been playing professionally.
- How good are you at Bubble Hockey?
- I could be taken in Bubble Hockey.
- [Gary] Okay, we'll do that
Only 'cause it's been a while.
- [Gary] Liz, Dani.
Dani, you don't know what--
- [Danielle] I don't know what
you guys are talking about.
- You've never seen the
hockey game with the big.
- [Danielle] Jodie, do you?
- [Jodie] I don't know.
I am obsessed with sports.
I don't know what bubble hockey is.
- Okay, Bubble Hockey is the
machine that's in a bubble
and you see it in the Arcade
and people play hockey.
- Oh, that's what it's called?
Yes, I know what that is.
- Of course.
- [Danielle] Oh, you guys
are that obsessed with that?
- 87% of the brain comes through.
Alright, Jerry.
Hold on.
He's obsessed with Twitch, eSports.
But actually, in specific.
- [Jerry] Scouting
- [Gary] Scouting for 2K.
- [Jerry] Yes.
- Who the best player you've seen?
Or have you not been
able to draft them yet?
- No.
So what will happen
similar to the real MBA
is they will announce a lottery order.
And then we will all sit in the war room
and draft these guys.
And they will move to the city
and get paid to be a pro gamer.
- [Gary] When somebody is great at 2K
is there an advantage for them to use
the Warriors or the Cavs?
- [Jerry] See, here's the thing.
They use their own created player.
That's why the game has changed.
- [Gary] I see.
- So it's no longer like,
I'm gonna play you.
To answer you're question, though.
Yes, if you do it that way.
The Warriors are
obviously, major advantage.
- [Gary] Sure, of course; but.
But these guys are creating
their own player squatting up.
- [Gary] All of them?
- And they're playing five versus five.
- [Gary] Actual guys.
And do they have to be themselves?
Or can they create a seven foot nine XXXX.
- [Jerry] They can absolutely do that.
- But then they become
vulnerable in other ways.
- [Jerry] Exactly.
I love where we're going.
Liz.
Sorry, Jerry.
You're done.
- Scouting.
- [Liz] Do you want more surface answers?
- [Gary] You've been overthinking.
- I know.
- Did you talk to a PR
person before you came here?
- [Liz] No.
- [Gary] You're hedging.
You're name is hedge.
No.
My literal example
was literally a fucking pillow.
- Alright, well.
- [Gary] Liz.
- I don't want to get to
the whole Gandhi thing.
But, I'm really interested
in learning more
about the psychology of marketing.
- [Gary] Okay, keep going.
- And, I just think we're
so inundated with brands
on a daily basis.
And the consumption of media.
- [Gary] And just overall information.
- Consumption of media, information.
What have you.
And so, learning how brands
can break through it.
Not even brands, but people.
Influencers.
- [Gary] Anyone.
- Anyone.
- [Gary] Do you think
that you're intuitive?
- I believe so.
- [Gary] I think so too.
- Just in our one meeting.
And now, just some of the things.
I think that's a good space for you to go.
I think that's my space.
I know nothing about--
- [Liz] It's fascinating, though.
- What are you laughing at?
Okay.
(laughter)
- [Gary] No more siblings
on this kind of show.
No, but I think it's a good space for you.
Because thinking about...
A lot of people read that
Instagram raised money.
- [Liz] Totally.
- That didn't take them
to the place of, hey
I can make the parallel
of once there's attention here
that translates to print.
- [Liz] Right.
I think that's the only thing I had.
Using the sports reference.
I think I'm Mariano Rivera.
All I think I have is
intuitive understanding
of people's behaviors
and then I play that
playbook over and over.
Then I learn the context of Twitch.
I'm gonna have a huge Twitch channel
in 14 months.
Because once I put in the time
to understand the context, it's game over.
- [Liz] Totally.
- That's gonna be dope.
- [Danielle] Don't you want
to hang out with him everyday.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Does that go through your mind?
- Brain suck his ideas.
- I better be on that Twitch channel.
- Yeah, at a different level.
- [Gary] Which level?
(laughter)
I'm the female version.
- [Gary] As a tag team?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] You're like champions.
Alright, so that is what
you're thinking about.
So are you--
- [Liz] Yeah, I think
it's very interesting.
- Obviously, I know we got to talk
I'll sum up the audience.
You have this incredible situation
where you're smart and hard work
put you in this incredible spot.
- [Liz] I also had a great team.
- As a young entrepreneur.
- [Gary] Right?
Absolutely.
But, you're now in a place
where you can be thoughtful
about you're next step or two or three.
- [Liz] Absolutely.
- And so that's where
you're putting your energy
in trying to understand
where that translates.
Have you started thinking about voice?
Like Alexa and all that?
- I have.
I just need to understand a bit more.
- [Danielle] You're obsessed.
Careful.
- I'm really obsessed.
- [Liz] Crazy.
- I just know it.
It's all about friction.
- [Danielle] Right.
- Here's what I think.
All three of you and everybody listening.
Put an Alexa or a google
home in your bathroom
and learn that you can use it.
- Jerry.
- I just got it for Christmas
and I had it returned.
Yeah.
- [Liz] You don't like it.
- It's not that I don't like it!
I just...
(moaning)
- Do it with voice.
- Why did you need the 30 dollars so bad?
- [Danielle] Let's talk about it.
- [Jerry] No, no.
Meaning, I'm never gonna use this.
I don't want it.
- [Gary] You know who
you sound like right now.
- Like an idiot.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Yes, I truly agree.
- [Gary] We can literally
recall this clip,
we're filming it right now.
In six years, we're gonna
show this exact clip
and it's gonna be great
because you're gonna be starring
in Apple's home pod's commercial.
And we're gonna be, this fucking guy.
(laughter)
- Hi, I'm Jerry Ferrara.
Do you know what you need in your home?
- [Gary] An Apple home pod.
'Cause it's the bet.
No, here's why.
When people first got the iPhone
they didn't understand the power.
You don't realize the apps
that are gonna be built
on top of these products
that are gonna completely
change your life.
And more importantly,
the reason I like the bathroom move
is I do think a lot of
people think about their day
early on.
A lot runs through your
mind in the bathroom.
And so, hey what's my calendar today.
Hey, remind me to buy this.
I think about 700.
By thinking about my upcoming day.
Without even looking at my
calendar, in the shower.
I think about people I
need to connect with.
Things that I need to get done.
The amount of things that
run through people's minds
of to do.
- [Liz] In the bathroom.
- You have to understand
how the Alexa works.
Alexa, make sure I see D Rock later.
You know?
Stuff like that is intense.
Right Alexa?
- I think she passed out.
- [Gary] She's just not there yet.
- Alexa, are you alright?
- [Alexa] I came down
with the case of the acting bug.
(laughter)
- [Alexa] Close system, for now.
- What?
- [Gary] I'll tell you what happened.
I feel she just said
something to me right there.
- [Gary] She did.
She did, Jer.
This is what's happening.
Alexa is actually is listening.
- [Jerry] I'm scared.
And referenced your acting
career in her answer just now.
I'm joking.
- [Liz] What?
- Alexa, before I go
I want to know what you're obsessed with.
- [Alexa] Sorry.
I don't know that.
- [Gary] See?
But soon.
- This is the problem with Alexa.
- This is the current
short-term problem with Alexa.
And if you don't get
used to talking to her
by the time she's got it all figured out
you are all going to be behind.
- [Liz] But even voice authentication
will be more powerful
than image recognition.
- [Gary] Guys, voice is the fucking jam.
- [Danielle] Can we leave with Alexas.
Can we get little to-go bags?
- [Gary] We might have some.
- [Jerry] I'm gonna sell it on the street.
- Jerry you like that?
- [Gary] Jerry sold his for six bucks.
- You'll see me downtown.
I got Alexas.
- [Gary] Jerry sold his for six bucks.
(laughter)
Why did you need?
Alright; what are you
currently obsessed with?
- [Liz] Oh also,
I'm obsessed with those Instagram accounts
where they're icing cakes.
Have you ever seen those accounts?
They're mesmerizing.
- [Gary] Which is you're favorite?
Do you know?
- [Liz] I don't know.
Or you know image-based?
- [Liz] They're all weird.
- So none of them did a good job
branding enough to make you a member.
- [Tyler] With a squishy?
- Yeah, and they cut things.
Just look.
- You're talking about
something different, Ty.
- [Danielle] I'm obsessed
with a few things.
The short answer, Shazam.
And it kind of ties into the voice
and digital...
- [Gary] You love Shazam.
- I love Shazam.
- [Gary] Because you want
to know what song that is.
- Any time I walk into
a restaurant bathroom,
or a dinner, or a gas
station, or a showroom.
- [Gary] Let's talk about the last time
you walked into a gas station.
No, let's focus on this part.
Can we?
Tell us that story real quick, please.
- [Liz] Here we go.
- Let me think when I
went into a gas station.
(laughter)
- Alright, let's segue.
- [Danielle] But, anyways.
I'm obsessed with Shazam.
It's how I discovered
some of my favorite songs
in the entire world.
- What is your favorite
song you ever discovered
from Shazam.
- [Danielle] Well, right now
I'm obsessed with, I'm
gonna botch his name,
Ludovico Einaudi.
- [Gary] Okay.
- Obsessed.
Memories?
- [Gary] Yes, I got it.
- Okay.
- [Gary] Yeah, we're all there.
(laughter)
We're just waiting for the next part.
- There's a song called Luhya.
L-U-H-Y-A
- [Gary] Okay.
- I forget who it is.
I actually Instagramed the other day
in my insta story,
and they only have three
thousand Instagram followers.
I think they're going to be massive.
I'm also obsessed Jain.
- What's their handle?
I want to put this down.
'Cause I think you're
gonna with this game.
And we will also clip this,
recall it for you,
send it to you.
You can post it.
And you'll be amazing.
And Jerry will be a hypocrite.
- And there's a song called Porto.
I'm gonna send you guys a playlist
just for this crew.
- Why don't you start a
Spotify playlist right now,
around the brand.
Which I think is a huge
marketing strategy.
My Monday to Monday playlist
is killing it for me.
- [Danielle] Why don't you feature it?
Gary, Gary.
Why don't you feature it?
- [Gary] Why don't you
feature you're song on it?
- Yeah, 'cause you have a
way bigger reach than me.
- [Gary] No, no.
But look.
We're gonna use this audience,
and now you're gonna start one.
- [Danielle] You guys hear this?
- [Jerry] I would like a playlist.
- Alright, I'm gonna make you one day.
- Send me a playlist.
- [Gary] Can you make a commitment?
You're both in here.
Right?
You guys make the decisions.
- [Danielle] Yeah, you're looking at us.
- Can you guys confirm that by tonight
your brand
will have a Spotify playlist?
- [Jodie] It'll be by tomorrow.
We have a big dinner tonight.
We have a lot to do after.
- Your company is going out of business.
- [Danielle] Which, by the way,
you are invited to.
She's coming, too.
And you and your wife are welcome to come.
- [Gary] Tyler.
Do you know this part about my life?
I get invited to so much awesome shit.
- [Danielle] I know.
- Tyler deletes it.
- [Tyler] That's not true.
- [Danielle] Tyler.
I specifically said, can Gary come.
- Why can't I never go to anything?
- [Tyler] 'Cause you got other shit to do.
- [Danielle] Can Gary come?
- [Jerry] Fair enough.
(laughter)
- [Danielle] The other
thing that I'm obsessed with
besides Shazam.
I'm gonna do the playlist
by tomorrow.
- Go ahead
- Vintage.
All things vintage
and getting back to our roots
and old world, and story telling.
- [Gary] Our roots of the 1990's.
- Yeah, like in 1900's.
- [Gary] 'Cause you're so fucking young.
We oughta get back to our roots.
- [Liz] Dani find some cool stuff.
- [Gary] 1989.
- [Jerry] The late 1900's.
- [Gary] Oh, Victorian.
- The twenties, the thirties.
- Yeah.
- When things were much simpler
and women were wearing
corsets, and their hair.
- [Gary] So are you gonna
start rocking corsets.
- [Danielle] Yeah, actually.
- [Liz] We already do it.
- [Gary] But, I mean for real.
Not in like a
pseudo-interpreted 2018 world.
I mean some straight 1920's gangster shit.
- I reinterpret.
- [Gary] I knew that you reinterpret.
- But what I'm really excited
about is the usage of vintage
and things of the past
as a means to story-tell.
- [Gary] I agree.
In fashion, I'm sick of everything.
I'm sick of Instagram or fast fashion.
- [Gary] But it's 'cause your cool.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] You're biggest problem
is you're absurdly cool.
- [Danielle] Say it louder.
- Yeah.
You're biggest issue is that
you're outrageously cool.
- [Danielle] Thank you, Gary.
- Actually, on a very complementary kick,
you might be the coolest person I know.
- Jerry.
Should I walk out now.
- [Jerry] Alright, Gary.
- Alexa, did you hear that.
- I know we met 48
minutes ago, but alright.
- Alexa did you hear that?
- [Gary] Alexa, who's the coolest person?
Alexa, who's the coolest person?
- [Alexa] I like whomever
is talking to me.
- [Gary] I was talking to her.
- That was me.
- [Gary] Alexa is very smart.
- That was me, Alexa.
- [Gary] I think it was me.
- It's Danielle Snyder from Dannijo.
Thank you so much sweetheart.
I love you, too.
- Are you gonna become
best friends with Alexa?
- [Danielle] Yeah.
If you think she's that great.
- [Gary] I think you should
start an Instagram account
called your name and Alexa.
- [Danielle] Danielle and Alexa?
- Yes.
And you should post three times a day
of you and your adventures with Alexa.
(laughter)
- [Jerry] I don't know if Alexa likes it.
- [Danielle] Alexa we're
gonna make it this afternoon.
Gary's team is gonna help me.
- [Gary] Can you commit?
No, no.
You've gotta learn how
to do this yourself.
- [Danielle] I know, but Gary.
- We'll give you the playbook.
I actually think one of the
biggest Instagram accounts
sitting and waiting is somebody's
person's name and Alexa,
like these joint accounts.
There is something incredibly
creative that can be done.
- [Danielle] Conversations.
- [Liz] Scoop that up the second.
- [Gary] Well, that's
why putting out there.
And here's where often times.
Alexa, shut up.
I say it because in a lot of my talks
I always say that 99%.
The reason I give away all my best advice
is 'cause 99% of you
are not gonna take it.
The reason I just did
this last little skit
was in a week I'm gonna go
look how many people did it
and the reality is 1% of
this listening audience.
- [Danielle] Tyler is making
Danielle and Alexa right now.
That's what he's doing.
Thank you.
- [Gary] Does Tyler work for you?
I've always had this
secretly weird concern
this has been going on.
- [Danielle] Tyler and I.
- [Jerry] He's a double agent.
- [Danielle] We're like family.
- [Gary] I feel like
this has been going on.
- [Danielle] We're a family.
- By the way, all your people.
Ever since the first day I came here.
Jerry.
- [Jerry] You hired me outside.
She just hired me before we were in here.
- [Gary] It's a start.
- I told her I want to pivot out of acting
and she hired me.
- Liz and I are working together.
Jerry.
- [Gary] Liz.
Let's talk about the Super Bowl.
It just happened.
Tell me about your Super Bowl experience.
- I went on a plane.
So I didn't even watch it.
- [Gary] Okay, so let's talk.
- I missed the half-time show.
- [Gary] The Justin Timberlake thing.
- Yeah.
- Okay, so let's talk about this.
The Super Bowl.
You were on the plane the whole time.
- A majority of it.
- Where were you before you landed?
- [Liz] I was in Los Angeles.
- [Gary] And you came to New York.
- And I came to San Francisco.
- [Gary] Oh interesting.
Now, that was a five second flight.
- Oh man.
(laughter)
- [Gary] It's a short flight.
- There was.
- [Gary] Right?
- But it was right at when it was.
- [Gary] So tell me about this.
Who else was on the plane?
And was it weird?
Because you knew the whole
country was doing one thing
and you and these 200 weird
people were in the air.
(laughter)
But I also couldn't watch it
on You Tube TV on my phone.
- [Gary] So, you know how the pilots
with big sporting events
do this stuff where they
update, Eagles seven.
- [Liz] Yes.
- Were they doing that?
- And with half the plane be like yay
and the other half be bleh.
- I'm not sure I had my
headphones in the whole time.
What were you listening to?
Probably John Mayer.
(laughter)
- We have a secret story about that.
- [Liz] All my friends are
gonna be laughing at that.
- John's the best.
I don't know if you know this.
Danielle, would you grab
crushing it, please?
- [Danielle] Yes, I would love to.
- And can you go to the back.
And can you read what
John Mayer said about--
- John Mayer.
Quote.
"Gary is helping to calibrate the desires
"And expectations of a new generation
"Searching for a way
break through the noise.
"He's loud, he's high energy,
"And he's exactly right".
- Right.
- [Liz] How many times have you read that?
- [Danielle] Anything else?
- [Jerry] You can plan
that whole exchange out.
- [Gary] You know, actually,
you did that so well.
And I always like your voice.
- [Danielle] Should I do the rock?
- You should do whatever
which one you think is cool.
- I hope you're listening, the Rock.
- [Gary] Do you like the Rock?
- Now I do.
- [Jerry] You say it like
the Rock would say it.
No don't do that, I was kidding.
- [Gary] Can you?
- Maybe, wait.
Hang on.
I'm passing it off to Jerry.
- No, no.
I don't have a Rock impersonation.
- Let's see.
- [Gary] Alright; enough of Crushing It.
The best book ever written.
Let's move on.
- Dani.
What was your Super Bowl experience?
- So, I watched the Super Bowl.
I changed my parents flight.
I don't know.
There's a lot of things about
me that a lot of people know
'cause I'm an open book.
I'm Jewish.
The thing that everybody knows
is that I'm obsessed with my family
and I would do anything for them.
I need them near me all the time.
- [Gary] That's right
So my parents were here
and they were meant to fly over here
for niece's third birthday.
They were meant to fly home
during the Super Bowl to Jacksonville.
- [Gary] And you're like
Gary, what's your problem?
- [Jondie] You'll piss the Jaguars.
- [Danielle] My Dad is so
really beat up about it.
- [Gary] But you're bigger Gater fans.
- Bigger Jaguar fans.
- [Gary] Wow.
- I don't know if I've
ever met a Jaguar fan.
- [Jodie] We've had season tickets.
- [Danielle] We're from Jacksonville.
- You love David Garrard?
- [Danielle] Jodie should really.
I don't really give a shit
to be completely honest.
- Clearly.
You don't know even to who.
Do you even know who
Maurice Jones-Drew is?
- Yeah, he's...
- [Jerry] yeah.
- No, it's amazing.
I used to like to say, Joel Shmangy!
- [Gary] You remember
that from some years ago.
- It was ten years ago.
- [Gary] Okay.
Go ahead.
- [Danielle] Anyways.
- Dad's pissed; Gary's pissed.
- [Danielle] He's supposed
to get off his flight.
- This is actually why we became friends.
We were a Pencil of Promise dinner.
Well, actually we met during the naming
at South by South West, yes.
- [Danielle] South by South West.
That weird blah, blah, blah.
But the dinner at Pencils
of Promise was really.
And what we realized.
- [Danielle] Ah, we just.
The Gary thing was huge.
- [Danielle] Huge.
- There's like seven Gary's.
- [Danielle] We started
leaving voicemails.
- Do you know how many Gary's there are?
- [Jerry] There's a lot.
- [Gary] There's none.
No, no.
Jerry, there's none.
Jerry, ready?
Name Gary's that you know.
- [Danielle] We play the name game.
For real, go.
- [Gary] Not even know of.
You know.
- [Jerry] Personally.
- [Danielle] Gary Vaynerchuck.
- Gary Owen, good comedian.
Buddy of mine.
- [Gary] Yup.
- I've met Gary Shandling once.
- [Gary] Okay.
(laughter)
- He's not even a real person.
- [Gary] He's real.
- Yeah, I know.
- I think you have a point.
- Gary Snyder and Gary Vaynerchuck.
That's it.
- It's hard.
It's crazy hard, bro.
- [Danielle] We bonded over my Dad's name.
- I don't know if you know this.
This was the best.
18 months ago,
there was an article
that came out that said
the name Gary is about to go extinct.
That's it.
It's over.
- [Jerry] People are stopping.
- I knew that there was this.
I'm being dead serious.
- [Danielle] I might name my son Gary.
- Well, I know that.
I'm single-handedly;
I actually met somebody in Minnesota
at an IHOP that almost
named their kid Vayner.
- No.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Danielle] That's actually a dope name.
- [Gary] And the wife was
holding the little guy.
And was like;
honestly, our third one;
locked in.
(laughter)
- [Gary] Anyway.
Nonetheless.
Gary is about to become extinct.
- We can't let that happen.
- [Gary] I know that
there's a Facebook add
that you can run.
Excuse me, a Twitter add that you can run
based on first names.
So I run adds on Twitter.
- Oh, targets to Gary.
To every Gary.
And it's me.
I'm like, hey Gary.
It's Gary.
(laughter)
I'm sure you probably heard by now
we're finished.
- [Jerry] That is freaking unbelievable.
- But I won't fucking stand for this.
Let's rally.
And it was great.
All these Gary's.
- [Danielle] Can we pull that up.
- We could probably find.
I don't know if it was a dark add.
- [Jerry] You should
there's supposed to be
a Gary convention.
- See if you can find it.
It's like a Gary virtual convention.
- [Gary] So anyway, that's it.
Literally, you named one dead Gary
and one living Gary besides me.
That's it.
So you're dad, Gary.
- [Danielle] So basically,
I changed my Mom and Dad's flight.
- [Gary] Yes.
- They stayed, so they had
to leave the next morning
and their flight was at 8:00AM.
My Dad wanted to wake up at 3:45.
- [Liz] Make sure he got there.
- Everything was packed.
Whatever.
We got a huge fight about it.
I said this is ridiculous.
He says I'm anxious.
What do you want from me.
I stayed here for the Super Bowl.
I'm like, Dad.
- [Gary] You're dad is
stupid handsome, by the way.
- [Danielle] He's a adorable.
- [Gary] How old is he?
- 72, 73?
- [Gary] He looks 70.
- He says what do you want from me?
He says.
I said, Dad.
(laughter)
I said, first of all,
staying with your entire
family for the Super Bowl
is not a punishment.
- [Gary] Who watched the game?
- My dad, Greg, Jodi, me,
my mom, Margot and baby Lee.
- [Gary] So no random invite?
This is a very tight-knit community.
- Favorite term ever.
What do you want from me?
That's when you know
someone's exasperated.
What do you want from me?
- He's the man.
By the way, watch my insta
story on Danielle Snyder.
- [Gary] Who were you rooting for?
- I was rooting for the Eagles.
I'm so sick of the Patriots.
- [Liz] Yeah, agreed.
I caught the fourth quarter.
- [Danielle] For someone who's
not a big football whatever.
- [Gary] Yeah, fuck them.
- Eagles.
- [Gary] Is Tom Brady good looking?
Yeah, but I'm sick of looking at him.
- I agree.
- [Danielle] I like a
little bit of character.
He looks like an android.
He's good looking.
- [Danielle] Giselle is lovely by the way.
- [Gary] You think he's good looking, Liz?
- I mean, I just don't
even like him, whatever.
- [Danielle] I just
like a little more rough
around the edges.
- But, did you see his
outfit walking into the game?
- [Gary] No, I don't look at anything.
- [Jerry] Would you feel
differently about it
if you were Gary Brady?
- You know what's crazy, actually,
you know what?
The single reason I
love you is that scene.
The single reason.
- Oh, the To Brady sucks balls scene.
- [Gary] Except when you switch.
And that kind of made me scared.
And I was fuck.
One day, he's gonna retire.
I'm gonna rule the world,
which means I'm gonna
have to stumble on him
somewhere in my 50's.
And then he's gonna be this great.
See, Jordan's easy.
I hate Jordan, and it's easy.
- [Jerry] He's very easy.
He's a bad fucking dude.
- [Gary] He is.
Just so everybody knows.
Listen, you can be mad at me.
He's not the best guy on earth.
(laughter)
Brady, on the other hand.
seems like he might be.
- [Danielle] Did you watch
that Facebook live thing.
- [Gary] No, no.
Fuck that.
I've gone way further than that, Dani.
You don't understand who I am.
I've paid people to find shit.
- [Danielle] What you find on me?
- Not you.
I give a fuck.
I mean Brady
who I need to tear down.
- [Danielle] You don't
think I'm important enough?
No, you're very important.
I just blindly believe in you.
- [Danielle] I know, I know.
- You're the coolest person I know.
By the way,
if you're Instagram
doesn't have that quote.
- [Danielle] It's gonna be.
- And make your URL link to me.
- [Danielle] I'm running ads
for Danielle people on Twitter.
- [Gary] It's fans of Gary.
It works every time.
- [Gary] That scene.
That was like the best
but then you broke my heart at the end
when you switched over and said fuck,
he's a good dude.
- Do you want a two minute
story about that scene?
- [Gary] Unbelievable.
- And listen, I...
Not that Tom Brady needs to
get put up on any further
more of a pedestal.
- [Gary] I know.
But that was along time ago.
- That initially.
So, the context is in the show,
there's a charity gold tournament
and we get paired up.
And the Vince character
and the Johnny character
get paired up with Tom Brady.
And he's the nicest guy in the world.
I hate him
'cause I'm a Giants fan.
And he wins me over in the end.
- [Gary] And just for everybody
who doesn't know thing about sports.
- And I get a man crush on Brady
in the end of the episode.
But, that was initially supposed to be
the Vince and Johnny character
versus the Manning brothers.
And about a week and a half
before something happened.
They pulled out of the episode.
The whole episode was written for them.
And, we still had to shoot the episode
so I think it was Wahlberg
who suggested, listen.
And this is off the Brady
knee surgery season.
So he was just ready to come back.
I think I can get Brady to do it.
It'll be me and Brady in the episode
replacing the Manning brothers.
So he steps in, fills those shoes
and kills us.
Now we're re-writing the episode,
and Doug Ellen, the show creator
is like, what would your character
say to Brady.
Like, a Giant fan who hates Brady.
I said let's really get
the heart of New York.
I called my buddy Paul I grew up with.
Brooklyn as it gets.
I'm, hey Paul.
He's on speaker.
If you saw Tom Brady in the street
a week before the Super Bowl
what would you say to him?
He's like:
"I'd fucking say Tom Brady
"Fucking sucks fucking balls".
(laughter)
Doug went,
done, thank you.
Hung up the phone.
Went right into the episode.
You want to talk about things
that get quoted to me.
That is one of the quotes
that gets hit on me all the time.
- But you love him
is what you were gonna say.
- Listen, he bailed us out of a jam.
- Yeah.
- For sure.
'Cause we would've had a serious problem.
- I like Hitler more than Tom Brady.
Yeah, that's where I went.
I just want everybody to understand.
That's my truth.
- [Gary] I hate Tom Brady.
I, Gary Vaynerchuck, hate...
You have to understand.
There's real life, and
then there's the Jets.
- [Jerry] I knew that was gonna come.
To me, it's very simple.
Everything in real life,
99% of my life,
is very good.
I'm a good guy,
I do the right thing.
I don't say ludicrous
things like I just said.
I'm a good guy.
In Jets life,
let me give you a good one.
In Jets life.
'Cause you have the letter D.
- [Danielle] This is great.
In Jets life,
let me give you a great story.
I don't know.
Seven years ago at the Meadowlands,
just walking,
11-year old boy,
maybe nine,
walking by with a Brady jersey;
I checked him.
(laughter)
And I just want everybody to know.
This is literally child abuse.
I check a kid.
I check him.
I bump into him.
He goes into the fence.
His dad looks at me,
ready.
I go, what the fuck are
you gonna do about it?
Guys, you don't understand.
- [Jerry] I get it.
- [Gary] Jake, were you there
when I punched the Dolphins.
- [Tyler] Yeah, the game in Pittsburgh.
Oh, ready?
Pittsburgh game.
Jets were playing Pittsburgh.
The Jets miraculously in this season
win four or five games.
Miraculously beat a very
good Pittsburgh team at home.
So Pittsburgh, for
anybody who knows the NFL,
they travel.
Half the stadium is Steelers fans.
I don't like when people come to my house
and disrespect me.
This 87-year old man
is walking up the stairs.
- No.
- [Gary] Stick with me.
He's 87.
Tyler is...
He's walking up the stairs
slowly.
Right?
The Jets have clearly won.
It's late fourth quarter,
23-6.
I stand up and I go.
Hey old man!
- [Liz] No.
- You're finished!
Right?
Everybody hears me.
Hey old man!
You're fucking finished.
- [Jerry] Are you referring
to the Steelers or him?
And then I go.
And I don't mean the game!
(laughter)
That literally happened.
So look--
- [Liz] So you're an abusive Jets fan.
I'm a very bad person.
- [Jodie] Do you want to own the Jets?
- I do want to own the Jets.
- Sorry I jet felt like I had to.
- I do.
Let's move on before I lose all my fans.
(laughter)
You're Super Bowl experience, Jer.
- We hosted some friends.
- [Gary] You and your wife .
- Me and my wife,
Hosting friends.
And I think I consumed
about 4,500 calories.
- [Gary] Like what?
- Oh, there was like a Chili situation
and a homemade guacamole,
and buffalo cauliflower.
And then we got ice cream form this place
and that's where it all
went terribly wrong.
- [Gary] What place?
Do you want to--
- OddFellows in Williamsburg.
Great place.
- [Gary] You know of this?
Ample Hills is pretty good, too.
- [Jerry] They got a flavor
called Santa's cookies.
Let me tell you.
(laughter)
- I have an interesting
relationship with food.
- That's when we figured
out what he's obsessed with.
- And I made a promise to myself.
Okay, I'm gonna have all this.
And then, when everyone leaves,
I even said to my wife,
we're throwing this
freaking ice cream away.
- [Liz] And it didn't get thrown out.
- And then when I was
getting ready to do it
I'm like, we should give it one more day.
So, one more day.
- [Gary] So yesterday you ate a ton.
- Yesterday, bled into the Monday.
- Why didn't you bring any?
- And it's still there
by the way guys.
It's still.
- Should we go over after this?
- And here's how sick I am.
I walk around this day,
three times since I've
been to your offices
I've thought about,
Oh I got that fucking
ice cream when I go home.
(laughter)
- No.
- [Jerry] Three separate times
since I've been in your office
I've thought about that ice cream.
- You're hired, your hired, your hired.
- So, that's really what I made.
Being that I wasn't that
interested in the game
and I love football.
But the game didn't interest me.
I made it about the food.
- [Gary] D, what is your favorite
current App on your phone?
Like new.
New favorite app.
Or do you not have one?
'Cause this is actually an
interesting debate for me.
And I'll let you guys use that.
Because one of the things
that's interesting to me
is how difficult it is.
Actually, how about this?
When's the last time you downloaded
a new app for your phone?
D?
- Probably something related to filter.
- [Gary] That's fine.
But when?
- Maybe a month ago.
- [Gary] Okay.
Liz?
- I downloaded the Sephora app yesterday.
- [Gary] Respect.
Jer?
- I don't want to say.
- [Gary] Please do.
This, I won't make fun of.
'Cause I don't think I've
downloaded an app in months.
- [Jerry] No, you can make fun of it
because I downloaded Venmo.
Because I didn't really
understand how it works.
- [Gary] Let me tell you
something about Venmo.
I was one of the first three
investors in Venmo in 2009.
And it's the best investment I ever made.
- [Jodie] Really?
- Yeah, but guess what.
- You're so smart.
- Yes, I am.
(laughter)
But
- [Danielle] I love the--
- It's the best investment I made,
and the worst.
It was the best
'cause there's not much
I've been more right about.
It was the worst because
they sold so early,
the economics to being right
weren't even remotely close.
I made way more money on being wrong
and that is probably one
of the most right things.
So, you're right though.
You just fucking downloaded Venmo.
- [Jerry] I know.
You want to know how it happened?
(laughter)
You want to know why it happened?
- [Gary] Yes.
It's because I won my fantasy league,
and they're like, we gotta pay you.
And I'm like, cash?
- [Gary] I love the humble brag
of the fantasy league.
Did you dominate?
Who did you crush?
Name one of your buddies right now,
and be eat shit, Rick.
- Taylor is his name.
I got you, sorry it happened.
And he had tall girl
who you put up 48 points
and I still managed to win.
- [Gary] Jake, last time
you downloaded an app.
- [Jake] Last night.
- Jesus Christ.
- [Danielle] What'd you download?
- Last time?
- It was probably six months ago.
- Tyler?
- [Tyler] Three weeks ago.
- Three weeks ago. What was it?
- [Tyler] Water Minder.
- Water Minder?
- [Tyler] It sends me
notifications to drink more water.
- Interesting.
- [Danielle] I need to do that.
- Has it been working?
No.
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- Okay, respect.
- [Jerry] You need an app for that?
- [Danielle] Tyler can you text me that
- A month?
What was it?
Biscoot.
- Probably about a month.
- What do you think it was?
- The seconds app for stair master.
- Okay.
- D Rock?
- [D Rock] Map my run.
- What's that?
- Map my run.
- [D Rock] For running.
- Yeah.
I've heard of it.
- [Danielle] You want to know why
I don't download more apps.
Two reasons.
In case you were wondering.
One: I'm at capacity on my iPhone.
- [Gary] What iPhone do you have?
- [Danielle] Jay, what am I?
Eight?
- [Jodie] Yeah.
- It's good.
I take better photos
than all my ten friends.
But, the problem is,
in addition to being at capacity,
it slows your thing down,
it so overwhelming to have another thing
to look at in the day.
- [Gary] Your only seven of'em.
- Exactly.
I should wipe out the whole phone.
- You know?
Alright.
What do you want to yap about, Liz?
Open forum.
What's interesting?
- You're putting me on the spot now.
- [Gary] I am.
You could also talk to the community
and maybe ask them a question.
You could ask us a question if you want.
You can take this anywhere.
Open forum.
As if we were not even in the room.
- Can Dani go first?
- Nope.
She sure can't.
- [Gary] Jerry can, but he's not going to.
- [Jerry] I'm not gonna let you off.
- So we're all gonna look
at you awkwardly, Liz.
- [Liz] Okay.
Cool.
I don't know.
I think it's just the evolution
of ourselves and
how we portray ourselves digitally.
- [Gary] Okay.
- So, what are you
thinking is next for you?
What are you thinking is next for you?
- And do you mean from the perspective
of what frontiers do you want to attack?
Or are you talking about,
are we living PR'd versions
of ourselves online.
- [Liz] Yeah.
- Like, one of the reasons
I think Dani is so cool
is if you see her Instagram, she's cool.
- [Liz] Okay, you've
said this five times now.
- I'm trying to gas her up.
- Thank you.
I love you, Gary.
- Do you feel like you're living
a totally different life online,
or do you think that's your life?
- I think two things.
- [Gary] Please.
- I think we're living in an age
where we have to be two versions.
The real version and the digital version.
- Can I ask you a question?
And all of you.
'Cause I think this is
far more interesting
than this conversation
'cause I think we all know
this is in the zeitgeist.
I just think that's just
what always happened.
I think we always lived a life outside.
- [Jerry] Public and private.
- That's right.
And for a lot of us,
you come from a family,
especially my immigrant family,
nothing left the house.
Everything that happened
in those four walls.
Nothing.
We would fucking be
no teeth.
And everybody would walk out and be ding
- [Jerry] We're fine.
- [Gary] No dirty
laundry ever, ever, ever.
And so, using the 40-year old moms.
Cool.
So now you're doing at an Instagram,
but that used to be meeting up for tea
and never talking about the real shit.
So I think that
everybody wants to fear monger technology.
- [Danielle] Totally.
- Oh.
Social media made us do this.
No.
This just scales what we've always done.
- We were talking about
it outside, weren't we?
About other people.
- [Gary] On your other podcast.
- Right, yeah.
- That comes out at 6:00PM, right?
6:00PM
- [Danielle] Push it out.
No, we were.
I think it's...
I think what you're
saying is 100% accurate.
I think we're just more aware of it
because we can physically see it.
- [Gary] It's at scale.
- Yeah, but what about Gen Z.
I don't think they realize it.
I think they are living their true life,
digitally.
- Because their less
worried about circumstances.
In classic teenage form.
- [Liz] Because I think their less
aware of all of this.
- [Gary] Or,
they're smarter and realize
none of it actually matters.
- Maybe.
- [Gary] Because I remember
being in early social
media and I was like,
kids, don't put up your beer pong pictures
'cause college won't let you in.
Like USC didn't fucking know.
- [Danielle] Yeah.
- Jer.
- You got me hooked on,
so we're talking about your family.
I think you can go one of two ways.
You obviously embraced it,
but also on a business perspective,
but also seeing the way
the world was going.
At what point did you make that choice.
'Cause you were raised
to not let the private out
and you've matured and grown.
- [Gary] I've lost
everything you just said
'cause something weird just happened.
Please for the love of God
tell me your socks are not Lakers socks
when your a Knicks fan.
- No, no.
Come on.
Pistol Pete Maravich ladies and gentlemen.
- [Gary] Okay, at least
that's a little bit better.
- A little bit?
Oh, come on.
You don't have love for Pistol Pete?
- [Gary] I love Pistol Pete.
But I don't like wearing any other team
but my team shit.
- [Jerry] I won't wear anything that's
of my generation, you know?
- Even when your socks are dirty.
- [Gary] Yeah, okay.
- If it's pre-my generation.
- [Gary] I literally, you were talking
and I loved where you were going.
Literally,
it was like the best thing
you said this whole podcast.
Then I looked out.
And I'm like, if he's wearing Kobe socks,
who by the way I love in a lot of ways.
- [Jerry] But I wouldn't wear Kobe socks.
I love Kobe, but yes.
Let the record show, I
would not wear Kobe socks.
- [Gary] Are you and Kobe best friends?
- No.
- [Gary] Have you me Kobe?
- I've met him, yes.
But no, we're not best friends.
- Who's your best sports friend?
- [Jerry] Oh, man.
- This is a fun game.
- [Liz] Yeah.
- I love this game.
- [Gary] You have an answer?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I can't wait to hear that.
- Describe best friend.
- Who, who's a professional athlete
which you deem you have
the best relationship with.
(laughter)
- If you texted them
right now, they reply.
If you were like, hey
come over for dinner,
they'd be cool.
- Oh, I have an answer.
- [Gary] Who,
that is a professional athlete,
tell the truth.
- Can I look through my phone?
- [Gary] You can while Dani goes.
Yeah, that's fine, go ahead.
Mr. I've got so many sports friends.
- [Danielle] By the way,
I didn't say so many.
I was just more secure
with Jerry what gonna say.
- [Gary] No, no.
Not you.
I was talking about Jerry.
He makes sense that he has a lot.
- [Danielle] Misty Copeland, for sure.
But that's a,
she's a ballerina.
It's a little different.
I'm not gonna be, bring over all of the--
- [Gary] Actually, and I'm not joking.
This is not like a I'm
gonna get razzed on.
I think a lot of things
sports that people don't.
I'm asking you.
Do ballerinas consider
being a ballerina a sport?
- 100%
- [Gary] Cool.
I believe that.
- [Danielle] Should we
call Misty right now?
- No.
I fully believe that.
That wasn't a leading question in any way.
I actually didn't know
how it was positioned.
And Andy Roddick is dope.
I like Andy.
- Andy is your second
closest sports friend.
- [Danielle] But, okay.
Close is not.
- [Gary] Right.
- Brooklyn is a really
good friend of mine.
- [Gary] She's crushing
on that show, right?
- She's amazing.
Andy is a stand up guy.
I really like Andy.
- [Gary] Respect.
Liz?
- I think you know him.
Mr. Nigel Sylvester.
- [Gary] Yes.
He's fucking awesome.
- [Liz] He is amazing.
- He just hit me up, am I seeing him?
Did you talk to him?
- [Danielle] Gary, what about you?
- That's a good fucking question.
Top ten, baby.
- [Jerry] Right?
- No, what I mean is,
I don't want to be like
yeah me and this person are friends
and they hear this podcast
and they're like, oh.
- By the way, I disclaimer.
Jerry, I disclaimer.
I'm a friend with the wife.
- Instagram has changed my whole world.
Because, every time an athlete.
- [Danielle] I want to hear all of them.
I'm a hardcore fan of baseball players,
so I'm in love with Devon Travis.
He's been hurt his two years
at the Blue Jays.
But when he followed me, I'm like
fucking yes.
And nobody outside of a Blue
Jays fan should be pumped
- That's who you were
the most excited about?
- No.
Probably the most excited.
- [Danielle] How about the Rock.
The Rock we lost our shit.
When the Rock followed me on Instagram.
'Cause he doesn't follow anybody.
- [Danielle] Did you ask him to follow me?
- We all shut down and were like,
alright, what does this mean?
(laughter)
The craziest part about that.
- [Jerry] How will we do?
- That happened in a three week period
where the Rock, Kevin
Hart and Metro Boomin
all followed me, and I was like,
okay, something's happened.
- [Jerry] A billion people right there.
- [Danielle] What happened?
Explain it.
- I was penetrating the attention graph.
- [Danielle] How'd you penetrate?
- I penetrated by putting
out the best fucking content
contextual to Instagram.
- [Danielle] Should you
do a takeover for me?
- No.
(laughter)
Jerry, what's your answer?
- Well, and the reason why I
said let me look at my phone
is not 'cause oh there's so many.
It's I don't want to say,
oh me and this person are cool
and then they hear this podcast and like,
we're not that freaking cool.
- [Gary] No, that's exactly right.
- I don't want to be presumptuous.
- [Gary] And by the way, for me too.
Like Curtis Martin.
I'm thinking about the people like
Draymond Green.
These are people I have really
great relationships with.
- [Jerry] Yeah.
I don't think anybody of them
would consider me one of their
five or six best friends.
- [Danielle] Me neither.
- I haven't gotten to
that place with them.
I expect it to happen.
- [Danielle] But you're cool.
Brandon Marshall is probably closest.
- Me and Wes Matthews are pretty cool.
- [Gary] Who?
- Wes Matthews.
- [Gary] Yup.
I've met Frank Kaminsky.
A lot of NBA guys.
- [Gary] Yup.
'Cause they know how big
of a fan I am of the NBA.
He's not an athlete, but he's a coach.
- Should I call Tom Brady.
- This guy I could maybe get.
- [Gary] Shhh.
- I might be able to get
him to show up for me
if I ever need
Coach Calipari.
- [Gary] Really?
- He coached me at a
fantasy camp one time.
He was my coach of my team.
- [Gary] And you guys really went crazy.
- And we, let me tell you.
- Did you guys make out?
- No, no.
- [Gary] But close.
- But how I like to describe him
is almost like if Frank
Sinatra was a coach.
That's how cool he is.
- [Danielle] That's pretty cool.
- It just makes you feel,
he really does make you feel special.
And that dude is unbelievable.
Coach Cal.
- I was just saying if you wanted.
- [Gary] Open forum, go D.
- I just think we're living
in a really interesting time.
And I personally coming from
the vantage point of fashion,
and being our tenth year anniversary,
I'm having a hard time grappling with
the way that the world is moving.
Especially now that I have a niece
and nephew in my life
and I'm watching the interactions,
and the way that digital
is affecting them.
- [Gary] I see.
- Mommy and Daddy, and Aunt.
- [Gary] You feel bad about that?
- Everyone's on their phone.
I do.
- I think your niece and nephew
should spend more time
on technology, not less.
I really do.
I understand.
But, I'm saying things here today.
I mean, the Hitler thing
I'm gonna have to deal with.
By the way, real quick.
I didn't mean it, everyone.
My great, great grandparents got killed.
Buried themselves.
So, please.
Before I have to spend an hour and a half
on Twitter apologizing,
I hope I understood the
tongue and cheek of that.
But I do hate Tom Brady at a level
that is ridiculously uncomfortable.
- [Danielle] That's why I didn't tell you
he was my best friend of
all my sports friends.
- [Gary] The niece and nephew thing.
This is what parents
do of every generation.
Your parents' parents' made
them not want to watch Elvis.
Right?
Madonna was scary for kids of my age.
- [Danielle] He's right.
Miley Cyrus twerking a couple minutes ago.
Six years, seven years
ago is lame on Instagram.
What world do you think
your niece and nephew
are gonna work and live in?
- [Danielle] Do you want me to explain?
- What world do you think
they're gonna live in?
- [Danielle] Do you want me to really
get to meat of the issue?
Do you want me to really dig deep
and tell you what I'm
really trying to say?
- [Gary] Sure.
- It's not that I'm worried that
they're gonna be privy to whatever
on Instagram.
It's not some sort of censorship.
What I'm worried about is the
way that social media has,
the psychology of it.
How it's affected human relationships.
- [Gary] Can I throw a curve ball at you?
- Sure.
What we owe each other as people.
And what friendship really means now.
- [Gary] Let's talk about it for a minute.
A lot of people want to blame
a lot of kids troubles
on social media, right?
- [Danielle] Cyber-bullying.
I want to blame it on the fact
that parents are teaching
kids in their first 15 years
that they won everything
and their the best
and teaching no reality of confrontation.
When you give eighth place
trophies to a seven-year old
they hae no understanding
how to deal with anything.
So I think one of the
things we do all the time
is we blame other forces, not ourselves.
When you have a country that goes
through 70 years of
prosperity pretty consistently
We get into third generation dynamics
where people worry what
milk is in their Starbucks
and they think that's a bad thing.
We just have no context of real life,
So, I think what we've done.
Liz?
- I agree with you.
- [Gary] This is the world
you're interested in.
We want to blame things like that.
We all got bullied.
A lot of us who are over 35
lived in a world where,
when you came in second place,
you cried because you lost.
I think we have to
really be very thoughtful
about the way we're parenting.
Your sister, no matter what
is parenting in a
fundamentally different way
than your mother did,
and a fundamentally different
way that her mother did.
And like anything, you can over-correct
in one way or the other.
The micro-analyzation.
My parents didn't know anything
that was going on in my life.
And you take the generation above me,
they literally knew nothing.
'Cause they threw them
outside and they went.
Here's where my point is.
Facebook didn't make
you vote for somebody.
- [Danielle] Russia maybe did.
You know what I mean?
It sure didn't.
'Cause you clicked things
that made those ads
show up in front of you.
We have to take way more responsibility
before we blame social
media and technology.
And until we start taking accountability
which we have fundamentally avoided
for the last 50 years,
we will lose a lot of these micro-battles.
So, cool.
You want to blame technology
or something else,
but maybe if you taught your kid
how to take a fucking an L
in the first ten years of their life,
maybe they'd know how to take an L.
- [Danielle] Right.
What are your thoughts of
parenting in New York City?
I think that there's a lot of insanity.
But I want to teach my
kids how to take an L.
- [Danielle] But, besides that.
Do you think growing
up at a LA or New York.
We talked about this a little bit outside.
- [Gary] Of course.
You're a product of your environment
and of your parents, and of your DNA.
- I'm from Jacksonville, Florida.
You love me, I'm cool.
I think we should all
move to Jacksonville.
- [Gary] Oh, wait.
You're from Jacksonville?
I take back everything I said.
- You know what I'm saying?
My dad's from Brooklyn and he's dope.
His name is Gary.
(laughter)
It was a different time.
- [Gary] I think parenting
is an unbelievably important job
and I think that the gravitas of it
for this latest generation
made them over-correct
in a way that is creating vulnerability.
I really believe that.
- Yeah but I don't even think it's kids.
I think it's us, too.
We're insecure, too.
- [Danielle] We're a bunch of big babies.
- Yeah.
- Meanwhile,
me and everybody I know that
had my circumstances or DNA
are cruising along
because we got shit on all
the time when we were kids.
I'm being serious, D.
- [Danielle] That's
why I love you so much.
Yeah, getting D's and F's,
and not being the best at sports.
I learned how to love to lose early on.
We do not teach that anymore.
There's this great fear.
Playing basketball with my little guy
and beating him and him crying.
Yeah motherfucker, grow.
- [Jerry] That's what I wanted to ask
in the open forum.
I don't ever let my nephew win.
- [Gary] 'Cause you're smart.
- But I actually thought of this recently.
We played a little pick
up hoops in his basement.
- [Gary] Dunk on his fucking face.
- I let him score every now and then.
I even said to my wife,
I gotta let him win a little it, right?
- [Gary] My brother AJ out there.
- [Jerry] It's not in me to let him win.
- I gotta wrap up?
He's giving the looks.
He's a killer
because
he didn't beat me in basketball
until he was 17 years old.
And when he did.
It fucking tasted amazing.
Because when you fucking let your kids win
on dumb shit.
They don't understand that gratitude
or the process.
And they definitely don't know
how to deal with adversity.
And so when Sally pants 49
says you're ugly on Instagram
they fucking fold like
cheap fucking chair.
Motherfuckers.
That's the show.
See ya.
- [Danielle] Oh you guys.
(soft music)